never in a million years did i imagine
when i accepted a job in 2007
to work for donald trump that he would
one day run for the presidency
to launch a campaign on a platform of
hate and intolerance
and actively win i regret the day i said
yes to mr trump
i regret all the help and support i gave
him along the way
i am ashamed of my own failings and
publicly accepted responsibility for
them
by pleading guilty in the southern
district of new york
i am ashamed of my weakness and my
misplaced loyalty
of the things i did for mr trump in an
effort
to protect and promote him
i am ashamed that i chose to take part
in concealing mr trump's illicit acts
rather than listening to my own
conscience
i am ashamed because i know what mr
trump is
he is a racist he is a con man
and he is a cheat